what seems to be the trouble oh chap
i've been commissioned to adapt my novel
to the screen but the words have dried
up
i need to find intervention
my damn name is you bonsoir
tonight i will use my precious mystical
gift
i've got it i'd like you to conduct a
seance at my home
this thursday the moon is full and we
must harness its power
perfect open epicart is a fool you said
so yourself
it'll be superb inspiration for my new
screenplay
is anybody there oh is that you maya my
spirit guide she was choosing carmon's
wetness
she's not still lactating is there
anyone
on the other side did you think of
elvira his dead ex-wife
i'd like to go into a trance
alfiera hello you're dead
[Music]
the ghost of my first wife is here with
us in the room surely you can see her
she's standing right next to you
are you drunk who's she my wife i'm your
wife
not anymore can he by any chance
touch her i sincerely hope not
not a coincidence that you haven't
published a word since my demise
finished the first act of my screenplay
elvira help me
she's dangerous charles you're the one i
love
i haven't the foggiest idea how to send
her back you're in trouble now
[Music]
to true love true love never die
something must have gone hideously wrong
it's not for the first time
oh something took place i can feel it in
my base chakra
probably trapped wind
you